murray venir et
comme vous devez tout ce savoir on a
rencontré quelques problèmes avec
l'arrestation de talibanesques donc
éviter de traîner dans le coin on n'est
pas censé éviter d'y aller
[Musique]
on doit leur montrer qu'ils tapent en
touche
comment je
vois pas pourquoi je faisais dray
neo
ici bas où on peut sortir
tant qu'on ferait mieux de laisser
partir
tu préfères protéger ses chiens plutôt
que tes propres collègues
des patients tout ça c'est ta faute
où est mon fils
à force de traiter comme quelqu'un qu'il
n'est pas
on finit par croire quand là
[Musique]
chat
était juste à côté
da fermer les yeux
rien vu
[Musique]
c'est clair
oh
où